- So there's been a lot of
talk about this travel ban.
Judge overturned it, said
it was unconstitutional.
I think we're not banning enough.
Since I got everybody's attention,
here's some more countries
I think we should ban.
First up Canada, your leader's too sexy.
No leader should be that sexy.
Scotland, bunch of men
running around in skirts
sucking on a bag full of pipes.
Italy, spaghetti people.
Next.
Norway, I can't let you all in,
you spell four with a J.
It's not fa-jor-tuf.
China, any country that thinks a cookie
could tell the future has
no future in my country.
You people are banned.
Japan, now I know that not
all Japanese people are robots
but all the robots are Japanese people.
Turkey, that's a food.
An animal at best.
That's animal cruelty if
you got that many people
standing on one turkey.
France, you and your flat pancake
could stay the heck out of my country.
You call 'em craps.
Australia, I can't support a society
that supports animals with pockets.
London, people don't know
the difference between
a cookie and a biscuit.
If you can't tell the difference between
a cookie and a biscuit,
you got no business coming to my country!
We beat ya once, we'll beat ya again!
Transylvania, uh no thank you,
that's where the mummies are from!
I don't need any mummies coming
here and stealing my life.
Greece,
that's just an unattractive
name for a place.
Ban!
Hawaii, first state to
turnover the travel ban.
Guess what, maybe you
shouldn't come here either.
Uh yeah, maybe we'll
go down to a sleek 49.
Finland, oh the birth place of Santa.
Not a chance!
You come in here trying to
distract from Christmas again!
You think it's a coincidence
their capitol is Helsinki?
Helsinki!
Hell no!
Russia, I'm sorry they
got all these tiny women
and little bit bigger women,
and little bit bigger women.
How many women you have
inside of your women Russia?
Ban.
Atlantis, people say it ain't real
but I still don't want
no half-man half-fish
looking feller swimmin' up
on my shore asking for money.
Iceland, I've seen Game of Thrones,
those ice walkers are creepy.
In fact, they had the right
idea, they built a wall.
South Korea, you and
your sexy K-pop groups.
You got all these Asian Justin Timberlakes
dancing around trying to confuse me.
I know who I am and I don't like it!
I mean I don't like, no
I mean I don't like you!
You cannot come in South Korea!
Uh Poland, now I like
their sausages but again
no not like that, not like that, no!
Also, one more thing about Canada,
your socialist healthcare
we don't need that.
Healthy people paying for
sick people, that's crazy.
Look, I'll pray for ya,
I won't pay for ya.
Thank ya very much!